merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur julien dive
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministre
l'agriculture monsieur le ministre
les mauvaises nouvelles sont
quotidiennes pour le monde agricole
crise de l'élevage de la filière
laitière appréhension la fin des quotas
betteraviers en 2017
et évidemment la moisson 2016 historique
historique car ce n'est plus une moisson
c'est un désastre mais n'allez pas
croire que je vous tiens responsable de
la météo vous constatez comme moi que
nos territoires ont souffert des
conditions climatiques de cette année
dégradant la qualité et réduisant grâce
trafic drastiquement la quantité des
récoltes dans mon département de l'aisne
ce sont plus de 200 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires qui se sont envolés
et je ne vous parle que de la période de
la moisson les rendements de blé sur
l'ensemble du territoire ont chuté de
30% par rapport à l'an dernier
ils sont à leur plus bas niveau depuis
86 le manque de trésorerie immédiats
empêche tout investissement
et la concurrence sur les marchés
mondiaux s'annonce rude pour nos
exploitants français sans actions
rapides de votre part l'été 2016 aura
des répercussions dramatiques sur les
années à venir
il faut agir et agir vite avant que nos
agriculteurs ne voit plus d'issue à leur
situation et que certains en viennent à
envisager les actes de désespoir
quel choix fait de vous monsieur le
ministre laisser disparaître des
exploitations ou aider les producteurs à
passer un cap difficile
l'état peut donner dès maintenant une
bouffée d'air pour les trésoreries
par exemple en autorisant le déblocage
des plans d'épargné entreprise des
exploitants qui ont qui en ont souscrit
ou encore en assouplissant les contrôler
jusqu'à fin 2016 telles sont les mesures
que les agriculteurs attendent et c'est
aujourd'hui que tout se joue pas demain
vous avez fait des annonces le 27
juillet réitéré ce 4 octobre
mais bon sens dit nous quand elles se
traduiront en actes nous avons déjà
perdu deux mois nos agricultures
s'offrent souffre il ya urgence
lorsque je constate que certains d'entre
eux pour toujours en attente du
versement des aides pac 2015 je
m'inquiète monsieur le ministre vous
avez je crois votre idée de la france ce
que la france elle attend c'est non
seulement une vision mais aussi des
actions concrètes
aujourd'hui
merci la parole étant monsieur stéphane
le foll ministères agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt le
président monsieur débuté j'ai eu peur
au début coup ma pitié les inondations
du printemps
le ministre de l'agriculture n'en est
pas encore responsable et heureusement
vous avez évoqué les crises et vous avez
évoqué un certain nombre de sujets en
particulier je vous le rappelle sur les
quotas et la fin des quotas sucriers ça
a été décidée sous présidence française
en 2008
j'ai négocié le fait que ça soit
reporter de 2015 à 2017
sachez le reconnaître aussi deuxième
point à vous dites est ce qu'on est là
auprès des agriculteurs je voulais
rappeler d'abord la négociation qui a
été saluée par toutes les organisations
professionnelles du budget de la
politique agricole commune à un moment
où lorsque vous débattez entre vous des
réductions de déficit de dépenses
publiques à 100 ou 150 milliards je vous
souhaite bon courage
si jamais mais ça n'arrivera pas vous
étiez aux responsabilités pour négocier
un futur budget de la politique agricole
commune
ensuite monsieur le député sur les
mesures que nous avons prises
il faut qu'elle aille vite je les dis
c'est une garantie bancaire qui était
demandé par l'ensemble des organisations
professionnelles
vous avez parlé à partir de là de
l'ensemble des sujets polyculture
élevage avec le plan de soutien à
l'élevage et des mesures que nous avons
prises sur le lait je rappellerai là
encore qu'après la fin des quotas
laitiers nous avons mis en place une
maîtrise des productions laitières à
l'échelle européenne qui marche et qui
devrait agir sur l'offre et la demande
et donc sur les prix d'ici la fin de
l'année pour redresser les trésoreries
laitières et nous avons complété
l'ensemble de ces dispositions avec des
mesures aussi sociale parce que vous
l'avez dit ça pèse sur le moral des
agriculteurs
ces crises qui se succèdent et il faut
être capable d'abord de leur donner les
accès des plus faciles à l'ensemble des
mesures sociales nécessaires pour
traiter les questions qui sont posées et
aussi les accompagner pour redresser
l'agriculture l'agriculture monsieur le
député pour moi c'est un enjeu
territorial c'est un enjeu économique
et je n'oublie pas non